[Music]
Comcast before the war narration I'm no
space genius but with the moon still
looked like it had just exploded seconds
ago if it was actually exploded 50 years
ago I kind of feel like it wouldn't this
is an awesome shot no question but these
two famous Washington DC landmarks are
not so tall nor so sturdy that they
would still be this upright while every
trace of all the buildings around them
like the fucking Smithsonian buildings
are completely buried or gone but cool
shot bro we built the tent you named it
after the Vietnamese new year human
hamster wheel symbolism which convert
earth sea water into fusion energy more
fun with fusion remnants of the
scavenger army continued well this story
certainly needs quite a bit of setup
doesn't it
towers of nope it's like after inception
everybody had to use that noise in their
movie two composers are credited in this
movie and both of them are trying to
combine to form Hans Zimmer to protect
for nine jack harper tech-49 never stops
to wonder about the other 48 techs and
why his callsign is so high despite his
utter lack of evidence of other texts
some might say he's a maverick am i
right oscar-winning actress playing this
role tells us this character is probably
evil from the moment she appears movie
dusts off the old make you think the
aircraft is crashed when we all know it
really hasn't routine in 2017 the
Superbowl is going to be played in
Houston and therefore the Houston Texans
would also have to win that Super Bowl
in order to stamp 2017 world champions
onto the stadium and I'm sorry
Houston that's just not gonna happen
also they're in an area that was once
New York so this is not where the Super
Bowl is being played in 2017 Paula snap
she fumbles disaster oh I see this was a
Tony Romo game then right chewing gum
fixes intricate machinery cliche oh so I
guess it's not a Tony Romo game then huh
a tricky dog just happens to walk into
the area right after we saw scavengers
lurking inside the stadium false alarm
is false that drone is out there
somewhere Oh drone 172 has a beacon or
else you wouldn't have been able to see
where it crash-landed earlier in the
movie you just want to get Tom Cruise on
a motorcycle
awesome collapsible motorcycle is
collapsible Tom Cruise is on a
motorcycle cliche I know jack just wants
to fuck around and explore but going to
the ground game is a terrible piece of
logic when trying to find a lost drone
using the aircraft would be far better
to cover more ground in a shorter time
span but whatever located 172 or a
former building since there are letters
etched in stone that make this much more
than a sinkhole train soldiers and look
where he's going so that a well-placed
lampshade can alert him to the presence
of a deadly cliff Jack falls for the old
ridiculously large globe posing as a
drone routine Jack gets all cocky before
he's actually out of danger signaling
his certain failure at escape
back-breaking fall does not break back
oh really seem to cause any real
physical injury to Jack whatsoever
because physics it's not time for Jack
to learn what the
audience already knows that the
scavengers are actually humans so the
drone shows up to kick that revelation
to a later part of the script drone
leaves because there definitely can't be
any more bad guys than any other floors
or rooms of this huge underground
building did these cables come from if
they're not here right now
movie over movie makes a big deal out of
his bike getting stolen but then it nor
is it and just shows him returning in a
ship at roughly the same sundown time of
day random book lying by his feet turns
out to have great significance to his
moral dilemmas discount wall-e Vika is
addictive plants with this in Snow White
and the Huntsman I'm beginning to think
someone at Universal wants to make as
many pg-13 movies with as much
back-facing nudity as possible
underwater sex Califano I know
science-fiction authority figures are
supposed to be assholes but I guess I'm
tired of hearing them in movies blame
people for things that are a hundred
percent not their fault the repetition
of this question should long ago of
tipped off Vika that something was not
right with the tech people yes yes the
tower viewer on the Empire State
Building we saw it at the beginning of
the movie maybe you could have saved
that for this scene rather than beating
us over the head with it so does jack go
off comm every single time he comes here
because it looks like a ton of visits
have gone into creating this paradise
and while Vika did act like this was a
new behavior she definitely wasn't
acting like someone who's seen this a
hundred times
tad has to talk to the communications
officer who has to relay messages back
to the technician and vice versa there
seems to be no real reason that the Tet
and the technician can't talk to one
another other than it's really
convenient that the technician can just
disobey orders without any real
repercussions Vika orders jack to pull
out there's only one Tet so that there's
an entire half of each day when the
authorities can't tell what Jack is
doing wouldn't any being with half a
brain build to tetes so this wasn't a
problem I think it's huge you're telling
me they couldn't build two smaller ones
from the same materials and have 24/7
coverage of all of earth movies cryotube
requires hardly any nudity we interrupt
this Tom Cruise sci-fi movie to bring
you pulp fiction
Victoria this is Jack she asked where
are we not who are we also because
Victoria answers this question wrong for
no reason it leads to a moment where
Julie is able to restrain herself from
saying I know your name is Victoria and
that's Jack and Jack and I are married
and we are all on the same mission
remember instead Julia now instinctively
knows not to say too much because it's
clear Victoria doesn't recognize her
name Jesus once you write this dialogue
don't you go back and take out the
opening voiceover that is basically this
same word for word because this is
somehow easier than simply saying dude
you were on my ship with me as a crew
mate and also we used to fuck discount
Darth Vader
this makes for a cool transition which
is why movies do dish all the time but a
violent gun butt to the temple would
kill a person like two fifths of the
time in real life it's not like the
forehead is some kind of consciousness
button or something worst blindfold ever
and that but at the gun which knocked
him out cold left just a scar on his
nose and unseen captor recites famous
literary passage before showing himself
cliche also how does Morgan Freeman know
exactly which poem Jack had connected
with in that fucking book these two were
married but this chick waits forever to
finally start spilling the truth to jack
allowing the movie to have a proper
runtime man there are only a handful of
women alive right now and Jack keeps
looking into relationships with absolute
knockout babes Vika is a dicket to Jacko
it's seriously unbelievable the Tet has
no control over the technician ship
whatsoever discount Tie Fighters sci-fi
movie copies the flying ships through
the canyon firefight from every sci-fi
movie ever
another post-apocalyptic movie that
can't resist showing us some old and
busted future for the Statue of Liberty
and what Canyon fight would be complete
without a narrow opening to barely
escape your craft through you always
want to avoid a crash but this ejection
system does not seem to increase the
passengers odds of survival by more than
1 or 2 percent at the most absolutely no
other drones came to blow away Jack and
Julia after the crash
this pilot somehow doesn't see jack or
the other helicopter craft thingy with
the girl in it from the way we've seen
Vika and Jack behave earlier in this new
pilots comm officer should be picking up
life science and spacecraft radar and
all kinds of other clues about Jack's
presence in their sector yet we need to
go through the clones flashback to Tom
Cruise does what he's always wanted to
do to Tom Cruise movie rips off the main
character has to fight with himself gag
from Star Trek 6 undiscovered country
oops stunt double got in the shot ooh
ooh does the stunt double have
flashbacks about Julia's stunt double
seriously you didn't know you were shot
you've been watching this fight the
whole time it's not like you could have
missed the gun that shot right at you I
know it's common for Victoria to lose
jack from time to time when he goes off
the grid but the area where her Jack
went was clearly not one of those areas
it's ultra convenient she didn't see
Jack fight Jack a minute ago also she
lost Jack and then one went upstairs and
vacuumed the rug why the fuck is she
anywhere but near her communications
desk also what about now can't the
satellites and bubble craft cameras show
Vika an unconscious clone jack on the
ground and this other jack running over
to save some strange chick as Vika
planning on doing any work today isn't
this cabin back in the original Jack
squadron would that be a radiation zone
to clone Vika and shouldn't she be
panicking that her technician just flew
with a strange woman intentionally into
the radiation zone futuristic tech heavy
movie scolds us that a tech free life is
the only true life worth living cliche
would look like that
well he looks pretty much the same as he
did when he left only cleaner I'm in
touch that troop ships down doors open
and none of these thousands of Jack
Harper's were in any way confused at
seeing so many of themselves running
around also memory-wiping must have
gotten really sloppy after phase 1 they
had an intern do the memory-wiping for
phase 2 Oh
Oh humanity that's racist also if this
is the kind of intricate nuclear
tinkering I think it is then do you
really want to tell him powerful
emotional secret revealing stories right
in the middle of it what if he screws up
the bomb man you only got one shot phase
2 was groans repairmen 50 years watching
those hydro rigs out Planet Drive let's
talk about the tetes plan they're here
to suck all of the water out of earth
great but it doesn't seem like Jack
Victoria and their clones are in any way
necessary they perform maintenance on
the drones and defend the rigs but they
can't possibly defend the rigs 24/7
which makes them useless during the
offline hours on the maintenance end how
do they not have the technology to fix
these drones with little worker robots
this is a race that is master of
interstellar travel and technologies
beyond our capabilities but they need
humans for maintenance 50 years those
hydro rigs our planet 50 years man hydro
rigs are horribly inefficient by the way
one of all these people been eating the
whole time there aren't much animals or
vegetation still around and we're told a
lot of people starved after the invasion
so what's the food source this drone has
its course Lady Anne and it's capable of
omnidirectional flight but these idiots
still feel the need to load it up on a
tank thing and drive it somewhere before
sending it on its way
unthinking kill drone just nudges jack
instead of blowing him away right now
falling down while running away from
danger cliche Jesus even the drones in
this movie up to stop in monologue
instead of just continuing to Massacre
everyone why because the main character
is standing here of course just when you
thought this movie had run out of
cliches time to outrun a fireball he
didn't die
inconceivable guy who was a hard-ass and
down to the hero now respects the hero
cliche is there a particular reason why
Julie agrees to go back in the sleep
chamber she doesn't know what Jack is
planning no she's awake she never asked
one question as to why this is necessary
jack discharges the sleep module which
is where julia retrieved the flight
recorder but then the flight recorder
somehow continued recording the cockpit
of the main ship when Vika says jack
also can the aliens not hear what's
going on inside the bubble ships they
created for Jack and his clones to fly
they're perpetrating the biggest ruse in
the history of the universe and they
didn't take the trouble to put
microphones inside these ships wait just
a goddamn minute the entire purpose of
keeping the human clones alive was to
repair the drones that protect the water
sucking machines
this footage clearly shows the Tet has
thousands of spare drones just hanging
around the wall waiting for something to
do
Ontario live there are species to
survive God knows why this matters to an
alien race bent on stealing water from
Earth and has been killing humans the
whole movie but okay we'll let you in Oh
Ted inside a tete tete ception
and another tat this thing is like a
Russian nesting doll also discount how
9,000 that's not the survivor you
promised me well seems like it might be
a good time to kill these fools right
honestly Sally was never that much of a
villain to blow the pg13 allowance on
her also hero must sacrifice himself to
save the day cliche they had sex one
time so of course it resulted in a
successful pregnancy and I wonder if you
see me and you look at her it's revealed
at the end that this is tech five to
Jack speaking but he should have no idea
that there's a child if we have souls
they are made of the love we share for
three years I searched for the house he
built
wait Jack built this house I thought it
was just a random house in the middle of
the woods how did he have time to build
this thing during his time as a drone
technician you the clone of your husband
wants should be like riding a bike right
also both cloning plot element ensures
the two heroes get to both experience a
tragic death and stay together forever I
have Jack Harper I thought you were Jack
Reacher
that's impossible better possible
[Music]
maniacal laugh I am Jack's complete lack
of surprise
for three years I searched for the house
he built I knew it had to be out there
[Music]
[Applause]
curious smoke crack don't you
you smoke crack don't you look at me boy
don't you smoke crack
you know what I would be doing all day
if I was
listening to audiobooks it's the perfect
way to catch some entertainment while
still keeping an eye on Jack in the
drones fortunately for you audiobooks
are not some space-age futuristic
technology hello computer they exist
today and the best source for audio
books is audible.com at audible.com
slash cinemasins you can find over
150,000 titles and get your first book
free you can even brush up before Tom
Cruise's next big sci-fi film edge of
tomorrow by grabbing all you need is
kill the book it's based on it's
freaking awesome
yeah so don't waste your days sitting in
a boring old sky tower doing nothing
wasted sitting at a boring old sky tower
while listening to audiobooks you may
think it's not an urgent decision but it
is check out the amazing selection at
audible.com slash cinemasins today and
get all the benefits of reading with
none of the actual reading the choice is
yours the decision is mine just don't
screw it up no sort of talk I've made
the wrong decision um nah